you've alluded repeatedly that Eastern
Europe is a part of the world that
people uh carry a lot of trauma and one
of the things I remember there was a
Russian psychologist whose name I won't
remember now who talks about how Russia
is one of the countries with the highest
rates of domestic violence and physical
child abuse yes uh where it's kind of
considered normal for adults to beat
their children to get them to behave or
whatever and he basically talks about
how that carries through and actually
there was even more interesting there
was somebody
who talked about how if you look at the
sort of things that people search for in
porn by country okay it shows a very
sadistic
uh mentality in certain countries in
Russia's at the top of that surprise me
yeah I mean I know where does that come
from uh lack of empathy where does that
come from trauma and where does that
come from Russia's history I mean the
you know Russia's been invaded by
everyone from the Mongols to Napoleon to
the Polish to uh Hitler swedes Lithuania
and then on top of that yeah sweetly
threatened to on top of invaded by the
Swedish how embarrassing and on top of
that they've added their own level of
trauma with the the gulags as you know
you know in your book you detail this
um the level of trauma in the Soviet
system was just a huge and endemic and
this is a wound but it's a huge wound
this is never to excuse any immoral
Behavior you know and if we wouldn't
want to understand it we should
understand that traumatized numb people
hurt people yeah because that natural
we're unless we're actual Psychopaths
which is a very small percentage of the
population the majority obvious like as
we were talking about sexual violence
there you know it feels gross right it's
not comfortable Pleasant subject and
that's a normal human response and that
can be cut off through the numbing of
trauma and particularly when it's
endemic and it's over time and it's
multiple periods it becomes a norm so
you see little Russian kids they're like
okay smiley they're happy they're active
they're and in a few years they're you
know the affect is gone on the face
right the the Russian smile you know
that kind of classic Russian look or in
the chest you'll see the classic tension
bands it's called armoring in body
psychology you know you can spot a
Polish person in the street in England
can't you because it was a certain look
you know in the body
um so it doesn't mean that everyone who
has trauma becomes abusive or unpleasant
some people go the opposite way they
become very sensitive and compassionate
but there's a good number of people who
that trauma shuts down that natural
empathy on top of that you'll see like
the drug you know Russian men die 10
years younger than Russian women because
of the rates of alcoholism this is the
average life expectancy for a man in
Russia 16 before yeah it's not great so
yeah the self-medication side of things
is there you know they made it recently
not illegal to beat your wife unless you
hospitalize her that's a law in Russia
yeah you can hit your wife unless you
could be hospitalized that's maybe
illegal but you probably won't get
prosecuted you know it works a lot with
the gay community in Russia you'll see
it in the way people other other groups
and make them them and US kind of thing
so it's in the thinking that scarcity of
is not enough and you will see that
worse all across Eastern Europe but
you'll see it worse than Russia and it
kind of gets softer as you there was a
story that that became viral of a woman
who
um the ukrainians were hacking a lot of
communications because a lot of the
Russian soldiers were using mobile
phones and they found messages from this
woman on it I think it was a dead
soldier's phone actually
um from his wife saying I know you're
going to have sex with the local women
but just use a condom yeah I've seen
that footage too yeah my wife showed me
that yeah and you're kind of translated
it because you're a woman yeah yeah the
[__] are you talking about it it becomes
a coldness to others yeah and the
Russian reputation for coldness is not
on deserved that's not you know I've got
it's like the reason I've got lots of
good Russian friends here but I do have
a lot of Russian friends they used to be
colleagues and people can be very loving
and caring once you're on the inside of
that and the same with my Jewish friends
but again that's another trauma thing
it's them and us it's your Insider
you're out every time I go to Israel I
put on five kilos because I get fed so
much in that sort of you know you've
gotta eat food or else we're gonna
starve to death it's a trauma pad you'll
see it in Poland too so you used to see
it more in Ireland though it's kind of
fading now because the famine was a way
back
um so these cultural trauma patterns
exist and they they run through us even
if we ourselves haven't had personal
traumatic experiences and I think it is
important that we talk about trauma at
this level and not let it just become a
middle class Pursuit
I actually emailed a lot of the top
world's top trauma peoples we run
Summits and conferences I know a lot of
these guys and I messaged them before
you created saying any advice and a lot
of them message back saying oh I don't
really know what to say because we don't
really deal with real trauma but I was
like you've made Millions from this it's
big business trauma now now there's
exceptions to that Stephen porgia is
great who does polyveable theory which I
recommend people look up uh David
pacelli has a technique called Tre which
is a shaking drama Release Technique he
was great he's ex-humanitarian so
they're exceptions but there's a whole
trauma industry now and this kind of
weird middle class far left politics
around it where it just becomes a way to
sort of beat people around the head and
claim status
thank you
foreign